many view video games as a way to escape
from the grind of our day-to-day lives
but in 2000 california-based developer
Maxis released a game entirely focused
on just that the micromanagement of
someone's life as they do chores go to
work and make friends The Sims filled a
niche that no one knew existed becoming
both a video game and cultural
phenomenon welcome to the history of the
sims it was while designing islands for
his first game raid on bugling Bay that
Will Wright realized that he was having
more fun creating the world that he was
going to blow up then actually blowing
it up
Wright wondered what it would be like to
breathe life into this world and began
to read up on urban planning he became
inspired by the works of Jay Wright
Forrester who argued that a computer
simulation could carry out urban
planning more rationally and efficiently
than a human ever could and also the
works of John Conway who created a
biological simulation called the game of
life which showed that with just a few
simple mathematical rules cells could
live die or even multiply after the
release of bungling Bay Wright continued
to tinker with the game's level editor
he would tweak variables and add in
elements like traffic and ecosystem and
people and watches the simulated city
grew and changed over time in response
he would read more into urban planning
and put the new theories he studied into
practice by coding them straight into
his simulator this side project would
eventually become Sim City while Wright
was confident that he'd made a unique
entertainment experience others weren't
convinced SimCity could neither be won
or lost in the traditional sense there
were no cinematics for example
brøderbund who had originally agreed to
publish it were confused asking right
how are you going to make this a game
his response was that the concept of a
game was merely a matter of perspective
Wright felt that SimCity was a mellow
and creative experience like playing
with a train set or a dollhouse because
the game didn't explicitly tell the
player what success was it meant
they were free to define it for
themselves still unconvinced brøderbund
declined to publish SimCity right ended
up shelving the project believing that
it would never see the light of day but
a chance encounter with an entrepreneur
named Jeff Braun would solve all of his
problems Braun who had been looking to
break into the video game industry loved
the project and together they founded a
company called Maxis to publish SimCity
in 1989 after a slow start the game's
popularity began to grow by 1992 it had
sold a million copies and was being
lauded by critics and fans alike it won
countless awards and was even used in
urban planning and political science
classes realizing they'd struck a chord
with the public with Hobby style games
Maxis continued to release sim titles
throughout the 90s including sim earth
and sim ant as well as sequels to
SimCity all the while an idea had been
percolating in Wright's mind for a new
game one day while playing with his
daughter he wondered about creating a
virtual dollhouse that would appeal to
adults as much as it would children a
personal tragedy would add another
dimension to this idea in 1991 the
Wright family lost their home in a fire
as they began the process of replacing
their belongings Wright wondered why
people bought things in particular
whether they thought buying things would
fulfill their wants and needs enough to
make them happy but in order to fill a
virtual dollhouse with things he had to
design and build one first during his
research for the original SimCity he'd
made an interesting discovery 3d home
design software was flying off the
shelves realizing that people wanted to
be able to design and build their own
perfect homes but perhaps weren't able
to due to personal circumstances he
developed a prototype game where the
player could do just that but that
wasn't quite enough to be a game Wright
believed that he needed a way to somehow
score the houses that had been built and
furnished a theory of architecture
discussed by Christopher Alexander in
his book of patent language put forward
the idea that the value of architecture
could be measured by the happiness of
the people who live in it applying this
idea right added sims to his
architecture prototype these virtual
people would live in the house that
you'd built and give you feedback on its
design but
working on sim ant a game that simulated
the behavior of an ant colony right
realized that these sims could be much
more sophisticated and play a bigger
role than just house critics he became
interested in time management realizing
that in real life there's a whole layer
of tactical and strategic forethought
that goes into our everyday behaviors
when asked about it he said there's a
whole subconscious time efficiency layer
in our lives in essence real time
strategy is our lives combining all of
these ideas together he began working on
the Sims with a small team at Maxis but
struggled to get the project off the
ground Maxis itself was struggling none
of the games it was releasing were
hitting the critical or sales highs of
its first game SimCity after
experimenting with different genres
including 1995's 3d pinball for Windows
yes that was Maxis and suffering a
string of commercial failures they were
considering acquisition offers it was
only when the studio was acquired by EA
in 1997 that they gained a new lease of
life with money new management and
Direction flowing into the studio Wright
was given the team he needed to put the
Sims into full production
in February 2000 The Sims released on PC
players could select a pre-made family
or create their own choosing the
appearance of each sim from a selection
of heads and clothes before assigning
them personality points into five
general categories the family could then
be moved into the neighborhood with
their starting account balance of twenty
thousand simoleons they could purchase
an empty lot or a pre-built and
furnished home in keeping with the
open-ended Hobby style philosophies of
Wright's previous games once the Sims
were moved in players were then free to
do as they please they could pause the
game and demolish rebuild and redecorate
the property however they'd like in
build mode will refurbish it with new
items in by mode live mode follow the
Sims through their day-to-day lives
while they did have some element of free
will for example they could go to the
bathroom if they needed to or would
socialize with those nearby players
could if they wanted to turn that off
and control every aspect of their lives
there was no primary objective to the
game but fail states did exist while
sims couldn't die of old age they could
fall victim to certain hazards like
fires or even taking a dip in the pool
[Music]
they could lose jobs fall out with
friends or wet themselves in public but
whether that was deemed a failure or a
success was totally up to the player
players needed to keep track of their
Sims eight basic needs which have
constantly deplete during the day needs
included bladder hunger energy and as a
nod to the games origins as an
architecture simulator room which
denoted how happy the sim was with their
current environment if one of these
needs is low it effects the Sims mood a
depressed sim will ignore direct
commands from the player instead
choosing to seek an activity that will
increase their mood like eating or
sleeping the floating plumb-bob
above their head indicates a Sims mood
at a glance the green in the plumb-bob
the happier the sim money was another
element that needed to be managed
carefully obviously the best way to make
money was to get a job every day a
carpool would pick up the sim and take
them to work and they could climb the
career ladder by improving their skills
and gaining friends or players could
just input one of the game's infamous
cheat codes for some easy samolians but
a huge part of the game was building
relationships between Sims by
interacting with each other Sims gain or
lose relationship points Sims could
become deadly enemies and fight or form
romantic engagements Sims in a
relationship could choose to try for a
baby after 72 in-game hours the baby as
long as it hasn't been taken away by
social services will grow up into a
child but as The Sims one didn't have
any kind of genetic system the child
won't resemble either parent The Sims
also liked a real concept of time I'm
not referring to the amount of time that
players would sink into it but the fact
that there were no days of the week and
that Sims didn't age the Sims was full
of wacky motifs that were become
franchise mainstays like the ups and
downs of the goth family and the llama
which would appear in all other sim
games in some shape or form another
unusual aspect of the game was that the
Sims spoke their own unique language
Simlish Reich was afraid that having
them speak English would become extreme
be repetitive to players and also it
would be expensive to localize and
record all of that dialogue for
different countries so right reused an
idea from simcopter he enlisted voice
actors who specialized in improv to come
up with a gibberish language not only
will players be less likely to remember
the phrases and become tired of them on
repeated listenings the gibberish could
be open to interpretation further
allowing players to tell their own
stories with the game a whole Fred funda
boiler critics and fans praised the
open-endedness of the sims and it
immediately became a best-seller in just
two years it overtook Myst
to become the top-selling PC game of all
time while Wright thought that the game
would have a broad appeal he vastly
underestimated how popular it would be
with women in a 2005 interview Wright
said I thought the game would have a
broad appeal but didn't realize it would
be as big as it has become half the
players have been female they play it
for a lot longer - it is more of a hobby
a huge part of the Sims success and
longevity came from how the games
specifically geared itself towards
building and nourishing a community
according to Wright the sims could have
actually released a year early but he
had been fascinated by the community
that had been built up around Age
software's quake in particular the
amount of time and effort players were
pouring into creating their own levels
and keeping the game alive long after it
had shipped when Maxis began working on
the Sims in earnest Wright wanted to
encourage this kind of relationship
between the game and its players so max
has spent time ensuring that the
community could easily create and add
their own objects to the game they also
provided tools to help users share what
they'd created with other players
including a storytelling tool where
players could take in-game screenshots
and write a story with them this website
was known as The Sims exchange in order
to capitalize on the massive success of
the Sims and to satisfy a player base
that was crying out for more content
Maxis began to release themed expansion
packs these packs would periodically
introduced a variety of new objects
architectural styles and even new
gameplay mechanics for a lower price in
the full game they allowed Maxis to
experiment with new ideas at a
relatively low cost and kept
interest in the sims hi the first living
large released just six months after the
base game the games one neighborhood was
expanded to five new npcs who would
become series mainstays such as sunny
the tragic clown and the grim reaper
were added as well as new careers
architectural styles and twice as many
objects it also enabled two sims in a
romantic relationship to actively try
for a baby in the vibram attic hard bed
living large was incredibly popular
almost 50 percent of players who owned
the base game bought it and unheard of
sales figure for an expansion eight
months after living large house party
followed now sims could already throw
parties but this new expansion added
party related items like buffet tables a
light-up dance floor and even TV host
drew Carey who would come to your party
if it was really popping off in late
2001 hot date gave sims more freedom and
more than 40 new social interactions
sims were no longer tethered to their
home Lots they could call a cab
pick up a date and visit the brand-new
downtown area vacation meant that Sims
could really get out of town either with
family members or friends to go on
holiday to a beachside resort a forest
or a snowy mountaintop
it gave sims a wide variety of new
activities to undertake like building
snowmen in sand castles taking up
archery and they could stay in hotels or
ruffit in tents and igloos Unleashed
added several major features to the game
and proved immensely popular with fans
families could now adopt four-legged
friends and while you couldn't control
on micromanage every aspect of their
lives your sims could take care of them
and train them the original 10 lot
neighborhoods were expanded to
accommodate 40 Lots including community
lots pet stores and gardening centers
all together on the same screen Sims
could also live off the land growing
crops in their back gardens and could
take their goods to sell at market with
superstar your Sims could pack in the
daily grind and try and make it big is
either a model Rockstar or actor in
studio town and you could follow them
there your Sims could win awards dodged
paparazzi and strut their stuff in front
of a wide variety of celebrity cameo
Sims including Avril Lavigne
Marilyn Monroe and John Bongiovi the
sims seventh and final expansion pack
making magic released in October 2003
and introduced magic into your sims
lives by collecting ingredients and
reading the family spell book sims could
cast spells and charms and even own a
dragon as a pet if you owned Super Start
you could cast a charm to immediately
make yourself an a-lister or if
Unleashed was installed turn your fairy
friend into a semi
[Music]
in December 2002 the sims online an MMO
inspired version of The Sims 1 was
released for PC for 9.99 a month the
game allowed players to create one same
avatar and move them into a world
populated by other players will write
describe the game as kind of Darwinian
who can build the coolest place that the
others want to hang out in he was
interested in the emerging social
constructs and observing players as they
formed guilds in fact there was even a
sims online mafia complete with its own
godfather who turned out to be the woman
who managed the housekeeping staff at
the Bellagio Hotel and Casino in Las
Vegas but the sims online didn't stack
up against the original game there was
no way to make custom content a huge
thing in the Sims and a key feature in
the game's biggest competitor Second
Life despite playing with thousands of
other real people players would be found
frantically trying to build their skills
than actually interact with each other
the game had a fully simulated economy
but it was totally destroyed by a bug
that allowed players to duplicate their
profits by interacting with a bugged
clothing rack in early 2008 the game was
relaunched as the free-to-play title II
a land where players could spend real
money to get ingame samolians custom
content was finally added but it wasn't
enough EA land was closed down just four
weeks after its launch
in 2003 the number one PC game in the
world made its console debut on ps2 Xbox
and Gamecube The Sims had two gameplay
modes the mission based get a life which
had resumed try and hustle enough to
move out of their mum's house and play
The Sims mode which was more like
classic Sims FreePlay the biggest
difference between the PC and console
versions was that there was an object
limiter on the console version limiting
the number of items a player could place
in their houses some items in buy mode
had to be unlocked in the getalife
campaign and houses could only have one
floor it also featured a rudimentary
multiplayer mode bustin out the next
console release was a very similar game
with a single-player story and a free
play mode but this time your sim could
get out of the house and visit other
locations the irbs sims in the city
offered some tweaks to the usual sims
formula as well as building
relationships and fulfilling needs your
sim which for some reason was now called
an herb had to build rep with other
herbs to gain fame and fortune and
advance to new districts in herbs ville
the herbs was the first Sims game to
feature a weather system and its music
was written and performed in Simlish by
the Black Eyed Peas
it was a very different time
[Music]
like its predecessor Sims two players
could build and furnish homes customized
Sims with the extensive character
creation tools and guide them through
their everyday lives but unlike the
first game The Sims themselves were now
a lot more complicated in the sims 1
they just required their basic needs to
be met but now they had personality they
would form memories and had distinct
once and fears which would feed into an
ultimate life goal sims could now be
family or career oriented or they could
long for money or power adjusting your
sims daily routine to meet once and
avoid fears added new challenging layers
to the gameplay if you wanted the best
of your sims you had to work for it
but the biggest change was the addition
of genetics in The Sims 1 there was no
guarantee that a child would resemble
either of its parents into after a
successful woohoo the female sim could
fall pregnant and the resulting baby
would inherit not only its appearance
but aspects of its personality from both
its parents babies could now grow up and
eventually have children of their own
Sims passed through six life stages with
each offering unique age related
experiences toddlers could be taught to
walk and talk children had to go to
school teenagers could have their first
kiss adults could marry and have their
own children and elders would eventually
die sims would remember important life
events both positive and negative and if
they constantly met their goals they'd
live happier longer lives
coupled with the family tree tool
families could now be complex with
lineage full of memories and stories
that you could revisit at a glance it
allowed players to become even more
invested in their Sims lives than ever
before but it wasn't just the Sims that
received some huge fan requested changes
players could now view the world in full
3d thanks to the game's new engine days
of the week were added build and buy
mode received their share of gameplay
tweaks and new objects and create a sim
was radically overhauled to improve
civic customization instead of choosing
from pre-made sim heads and clothes it
now allowed you to customize
almost every aspect of your Sims from
their face and body shaped the color of
their eyes a tool called the body shop
came packaged with the game and allowed
players to create custom clothing and
import it straight in to create a sim
Sims could now have a different outfit
for different occasions and personality
points and aspirations could be assigned
the Sims 2 was a hit with both critics
and the players and sold a million
copies in just 10 days
and hitting 4.5 million by the end of
its first year but the game wasn't
without its controversies former Florida
Attorney Jack Thompson called for the
game to be banned claiming that EA were
promoting nudity because certain mods
and cheat codes could remove the Sims
modesty blur that appeared whenever they
got naked EA were forced to respond and
they had to prove to Thompson that Sims
actually didn't have genitalia they were
smooth down there like Barbie and Ken
dolls naturally it wasn't long before
Maxis started thinking about expansion
packs for The Sims 1 they proved crucial
in helping the developer understand what
players wanted from the game sequel so
it was no surprise that the Sims 2 would
get its fair share over four and a half
years eight expansion packs were
released for the sims 2 and while packs
like pets and bon-voyage were very
similar in style and content to the sims
1 expansions most packs for the sims 2
made huge changes to the game University
the first pack added a new life stage
instead of transitioning straight from
teen to adult a team could now become a
young adult and study for their major
university night life was a mash-up of
previous packs hot date and house party
Sims now had turn ons and turn offs it
could go on dates but the biggest change
was that families could now own drivable
cars which were they no longer needed to
rely on the carpool to get to work while
superstar allowed you to follow sims to
work open for business expanded on that
theme and allowed sims to run their own
business not only was the game a life
simulator it was now a business
simulator sims needed to hire and train
employees earn skills and keep stock
levels steady other expansions worked
really well with open for business you
could sell cars if you had nightlife
produce you'd groaning cease
or even the pets from pets seasons
finally added weather to the game Maxis
had originally wanted it implemented for
launch but there was a bug that caused
it to rain indoors they couldn't get it
fixed in time so the idea eventually
turned into the hook of the fifth
expansion other packs enabled sims to
have four legged friends go on holiday
take up hobbies or just live in an
apartment instead of living in a house
but you could become a witch who lived
in an apartment custom content was still
huge for The Sims 2 and there were tons
of places you could download new items
Sims and Home Lots from realizing how
hungry the audience was for new things
Maxis began to release themed stuff
packs these were cheaper than the
expansions but included a load of new
items there were nine stuff packs for
the sims 2 including a tie-in with
clothing brand hmm
as well as everyone's favorite flat pack
furniture store IKEA The Sims enormous
success meant that the game had well and
truly permeated the public conscience
and nowhere is this more apparent than
with the game's music its popularity
helped draw in some big names mark
mothersbaugh of the pop band Devo
composed the main score and stars like
Lily Allen The Pussycat Dolls Natasha
Bedingfield and Katy Perry all recorded
Simlish versions of their hits to use in
the game
[Music]
it also meant the versions of the game
we're appearing on more and more
platforms the base game was ported to
home consoles and some expansions like
pets were ported as standalone games to
handhelds like the PSP and Game Boy
Advance three games under the banner sim
stories were released between 2007 and
2008 where you could play through the
story mode of pre-made Sims before
creating and playing your own the
story's games were mere tasters
specifically geared towards people whose
PCs maybe weren't high spec enough to
run the main games from 2006 development
of the Sims was gradually moved away
from Maxis and given to the Sims studio
a new division created solely to work on
the Sims
this meant that Maxis were freed up to
work on a new SimCity and an entirely
new project at GDC 2005 Will Wright
announced that he was working on Spore a
simulation that would allow players to
control life on an unbelievable scale
from the cellular to the Galactic you
could create a microscopic organism and
control that development and evolution
through five stages observing the
emergence of their intelligence social
capabilities and eventually their
ascension into space spore released in
2008 to a positive critical reception
and the game sold a million copies in
one week however EA's implementation of
strict DRM software secure ROM resulted
in a huge fan backlash and a
class-action lawsuit was filed by
disgruntled gamers spore received an
expansion and a couple of spin-offs but
it marked the last game Wright would
work on at Maxis he left in 2009 to a
small startup called stupid fun Club an
entertainment development studio were
the ideas they came up with could be
manifested in other media like video
games in 2011 he joined the board of
directors on The Sims Online Szold
competitor Second Life wall-e hasn't
been in the public eye with new gaming
projects in recent years Wright's
contribution to video games cannot be
understated in 2001 he won the Lifetime
Achievement Award at GDC
and in 2007 became the first game
designer to be awarded a BAFTA
fellowship his ideas changed the way we
think about videogames and brought
gaming to a whole new audience
[Music]
The Sims 3 launched in June 2009 it came
with the usual expected improvements to
create a sim you can now adjust almost
every aspect of your Sims appearance
right down to their voice
there was a slight switch up in sim
behavior and a substantial change to
build and buy mode that allowed more
placement options for items including
the ability to recolor and repattern
furniture at will but it was the
neighborhood that received the biggest
upgrade it became seamless and
previously when you wanted to send your
sim somewhere else such as a community
lot you'd meet a loading screen between
the two areas
now all you had to do was zoom out from
the Sims home lot and you'd be on the
neighborhood map without a loading
screen site if you sent your sim to work
you can now follow their journey across
the neighborhood and to make the sim 3
feel more like an actual living world
there was an optional new feature called
story progression which meant that all
the sims in the neighborhood would
continue on with their lives without
your input it meant that some sims even
ones from families that you'd created
could die form new relationships and
even have children sure it meant that
you had to relinquish some control but
it made the world come alive and let's
face it you'd probably already moved on
from those old families anyway
the exchange was improved to make it
even easier to create and share custom
content with other players while there
were a myriad of free items to download
there was also an official online store
featuring exclusive content that could
only be bought with sim points which
could be purchased with you guessed it
real world money one of the things now
available to purchase were worlds and
you could buy 11 new worlds from the
store each at an eye-watering $20
players could also use the Creator well
tool to make their own if they didn't
want to spend money and if you liked
expansion packs then boy was the Sims 3
for you EA shipped eleven over four
years most were inspired by previous
packs so you had the usual pets seasons
a couple of holiday packs and a chance
for sims to go to university some like
showtime added new ways to interact with
your real-life friends with in-game
messaging and the ability to send your
star sim on tour into your friends game
of all the expansions into the future
was the only one
offered a really original take offering
a futuristic vibe and new items to make
your Sims lives easier The Sims 3 also
had nine stuff packs including high-end
lofts tough town life stuff and Katy
Perry's sweet treats Perry had been
involved in The Sims 2 recording hot and
cold in Simlish for the apartment life
trailer however her stuff pack was
slightly controversial in that it was
double the price of regular ones perhaps
due to the cost of Perry's licensing
fees critics and fans alike praised the
openness of the game and The Sims 3 was
another enormous success for EA selling
1.4 million copies in its first week the
largest PC game launch the publisher had
ever seen with the sims train showing no
sign of slowing down more spin-offs were
to be expected
like the cutesy my sim series aimed
younger players which by itself has
spawned five sequels welcome to The Sims
Medieval right now I'm a king and my
castle is tight but you know what right
now I'm feeling barbarian in 2011 The
Sims went medieval this game was a weird
mashup between the Sims and a regular
RPG it was quest driven with a lot of
peril like plague peasant revolts and
jewels you could create your own
character and complete quests to build
up your kingdom to a defined end goal
sims only had two needs that you needed
to keep track of hunger and energy and
they didn't pass through life stages you
also couldn't really build anything
anymore
you were given a bunch of pre-made
castles and buildings and you could
decorate them but if you want it to be a
castle architect then you were out of
luck back in the halcyon days of 2011
when everyone you knew was sending you
farmville invites you could also bother
your Facebook friends with the Sims
social it was a browser-based version of
the game that utilized the social
network to send and receive items
between your and your friends versions
of the game in order to complete quests
with 16 million players in its first
week it quickly became one of the most
popular games on Facebook however due to
a bunch of bugs and a lack of new
content meant that it quickly dropped in
the ranks it was closed down just two
years later the mobile game The Sims
FreePlay is still updated regularly and
differs from main Sims game
in that it uses real time there's no
speeding up time here one real-world
minute is one in-game minute and
activities and interactions all take
time
in 2013 Maxis released a reboot of
SimCity it featured a new engine called
glass box which promised a more detailed
simulation than previous games however
the game's launch was a disaster
SimCity required a persistent internet
connection to play even the
single-player mode and there were
multiple network outages meaning that
many were disconnected from their game
or experienced crashes and even the loss
of their saves understandably fans lost
a lot of faith in Maxis and EA they
needed their new Sims entry to be a win
in 2013 shortly after the release of
Sims 3 university life and SimCity the
sim studio was reintegrated with Maxis
and in May of that year they announced
the next entry in the sim series the
biggest new feature in 4 was smart sim
Sims can now Express and feel emotions
based on events that were happening
around them objects and of course
interactions with other Sims the other
gameplay change is mostly focused on the
tactile precision an amount of control
now afforded to you as the player as you
customize your Sims and their homes Sims
could now be sculpted to look exactly
how you wanted them and I use the word
sculpted because you can now just click
and drag body parts and features to size
as if they were clay build and by mode
were condensed into one single mode you
could put down a room and as in created
sim simply pull and contort it to your
desired size you could even place
pre-made fully furnished rooms straight
into your lot it was a mode that worked
for those who love to spend hours
creating homes and those who just wanted
to rush straight into live mode custom
content was now fully integrated into
the game itself the gallery and its
companion app allowed players to quickly
share and download sims and lots
directly into their game but despite
these gameplay improvements something
about the sims 4 was missing in fact a
lot was missing toddlers a whole life
stage were noticeably absent when the
game
launched swimming pools a mainstay of
the sim series since the first game were
also unavailable huge seamless worlds
introduced in The Sims 3 one no more
creator style was gone there were no
basements grocery stores or school and
work locations on the neighborhood map
The Sims 4 was the worst reviewed
numbered entry into the Sims franchise
with many critics and fans bemoaning the
lack of features particularly ones that
were series mainstays
but while EA hasn't released any sales
figures for the game and despite the
complaints it has an incredibly active
YouTube community and went on to become
the first PC game to top the all format
chart in two years but compared to the
previous games substantial content in
the form of expansion packs has been few
and far between the sims 4 has only had
four expansion packs in the three years
since its release with the recent cats
and dogs being the latest instead of
expansions there's been five game packs
smaller than an expansion and bigger
than a stuffed pack they introduce new
gameplay mechanics like parenting skills
and vampires a lot of the missing
fan-requested features such as toddlers
and pools were eventually patched in the
game has 12 stuff packs with the
development of the next laundry day
stuff nope I'm not kidding that actually
what they're making being guided by
community votes a console version of the
game was also released and a mobile
version is in development for next year
with all the recent talk of the death of
the single-player experience and Max's
his own unfortunate forays into making
online Sims games work I'm incredibly
interested in the future of the Sims
franchise it's clear its audience is
still ravenous for it and that the
recent releases haven't quite lived up
to their very high expectations I hope
going forward that the Sims returns to
being the pinnacle of PC gaming
[Music]